ENGAGEMENT?
>> WITH HER CONSENT.
GREG: THAT IS ONE WAY TO SHUT
THEM UP.
HOORAY, HOORAY.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S TAKE AN
INVENTORY.
IMPLEMENT NONEXISTENT, CHECK,
GDP SOARING CHECK, TRADE
IMBALANCE ADDRESSED TRACK.
CLIFF THAT ADDRESS, CHECK.
THINGS ARE LOOKING UP AND WHY IS
THAT?
GREG: IF ONLY THE FLAG HAD ARMS
TO HUG HIM BACK.
IT FEELS LIKE A GOOD RUN FOR
EVERYONE.
IT IS.
SATISFACTION WITH THE COUNTRY
DIRECTION HAS REACHED A OF YOUR
HIGH WHILE TRUST IN THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA DROPS ANOTHER
LOW WHICH COULD BE WHY THE PRESS
IS GONE NUTTIER THAN AN ELEPHANT
WITH DIARRHEA.
[CROWD BOOS]
TROWD BOOS]
THAWD BOOS]
THANK BOOS]
THANK YOOS]
THANK YOUS]
THANK YOU.]
THANK YOU.
AS IT BECOMES HARDER TO DENY
SOMETHING IS WORKING THE HARDER
THE MEDIA WORKS TO SHOW
SOMETHING IS WRONG.
HOW DO YOU SMEAR AMERICA AS THE
THIRD REICH WHEN IT IS NOT?
YOU LIFE.
TAKE TIME MAGAZINE COVER.
THE SWEEPING YOUNGER BECAME THE
POSTER CHILD
SEPARATION POLICY.
SHE WAS WITH HER MOTHER THE TIME
AND HER MOM, ACCORDING TO DAD,
TOOK THE CHILD WITHOUT TELLING
HIM.
MAYBE YOUR HUSBAND IS BAD BUT I
DO KNOW THE MEDIA SPREAD THIS
PHOTO LIKE A COMMON COLD TO KEEP
PEOPLE ALIVE.
MEANWHILE, A FEVERISH BOLT IS
COMING FOR YOU.
>> IF YOU VOTE FOR TRUMP, THEN
YOU, NOT ON, UNDERSTANDING AT
THE BORDER LIKE NAZIS SEEN YOU
HERE, YOU HERE BUT WE NOW HAVE
TO FLIP IT AND IT'S A GIVEN THE
EVILNESS OF DONNA TRUCK.
IF YOU VOTE, YOU CAN NO LONGER
SUPPORT YOURSELF
SUPPORT YOURSELF.
GREG: THAT IS THE NEXT STEP.
EVERYONE IS A NAZI.
REMEMBER, ONCE YOU BRAND SOMEONE
AS EVIL THAT ALLOWS FOR ANY OR
ALL BEHAVIOR.
YOU CAN SHOW UP AT PEOPLE'S
HOMES BECAUSE THEY ARE NAZIS AND
PUT IN THEIR KIDS BECAUSE THEIR
NAZIS.
FUNNY THAT PEOPLE SHOUT NAZIS
AND THEY TOLD GREAT JOB
IMPERSONATING THEM.
IF DONNIE GOT DUMBER HE WOULD BE
TO DONNIE.
[LAUGHTER]
WHAT HE WAS MAD ABOUT HAPPENED
FOR TRUMP.
THE ONLY CHANGE IS THE GUY IN
OFFICE.
BROOKE BALDWIN, A RARE
EXCEPTION, GOT IT RIGHT.
>> HERE IS A QUESTION FOR
DEMOCRATS.
SO MANY PEOPLE ARE OUTRAGED BY
THE CAGES AND THERMAL BLANKETS
AND FACILITIES AND THEY WERE ALL
THERE IN 2014 UNDER PRESIDENT
OBAMA.
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS DID YOU
SPEAK UP AGAINST THEM THEN?
>> ,
>> YOU KNOW, ON THIS ISSUE THAT
WE GET INTO A MOMENT WHERE WE
ARE MAKING PROGRESS AND THEN
WHEN IT STALLS WE TURN AROUND.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: I DON'T THINK THOSE ARE
WORDS.
TALK ABOUT A DEER IN THE
HEADLIGHT.
THAT SENATOR GOT MUGGED BY THE
TRUTH IN BROAD DAYLIGHT
PEOPLE NOW CARE ABOUT THE
PROBLEM BECAUSE IT IS TRUMP.
GOOD, IMAGINE IF YOU HAVE FOUR
MORE YEARS OF SOME DEMOCRATS THE
HUMAN TRAFFICKING THAT HAPPENED
ONLY UNDER OBAMA WOULD BE
LARGELY IGNORED.
THIS ABUSE HAPPENED WHILE HE WAS
PRESIDENT.
EVEN THE LIBERAL WEBSITE AGREES
BUT THEN THE PRESS FORGOT THEY
COVERED IT BECAUSE AMNESIA WILL
NOT INTERRUPT HER ANTI- TRUMP
TANTRUMS.
TRUMP OWNS IT WAS TRYING TO STOP
IT IS ALL THE GREATER PROBLEM.
FACT, LONG-TERM TAXES HAVE
SHORT-TERM SETBACKS.
ADULTS GET THIS AND CHILDREN
NEVER DO.
BY CHILDREN I MEAN THE MEDIA.
THEIR OUTRAGES UNACCOMPANIED BY
AN ADULT SOLUTION.
WE KNOW SEPARATING KIDS FROM
PARENTS IS BAD AND LEAVING KIDS
WITH TRAFFICKERS IS WORSE.
I APPLAUD THOSE WAKING UP TO AN
ISSUE THEY SLEPT THROUGH UNDER
OBAMA BUT TRUMP IS EXCEEDING AND
THAT IS HIS NIGHTMARE.
EVEN IF TRUMP COMPRISES IT IS
NOT ENOUGH.
THE GOALPOST IS ON WHEELS IN
THEIR GAME.
HERE'S THE CURRENT LIBERAL
OPINION.
SPLIT UP THE FAMILY,
TEMPORARILY, YOU ARE A NAZI.
KEEP THE FAMILY TOGETHER, YOU
ARE NOT THE.
THEY DO NOT NEED SOLUTIONS BUT
THEY WANT FEELINGS.
HE IS A FORMER OBAMA OFFICIAL
EXPLAINING HOW TO SOLVE THE
IMMIGRATION PROBLEM.
>> I WISH THAT I COULD BAKE A
CAKE MAKE OUT OF RAINBOWS AND
SMILES.
>> SHE DOESN'T EVEN GO HERE.
>> DO EVEN GO TO THE SCHOOL?
>> NO.
I HAVE A LOT OF FEELINGS.
GREG: THAT IS ALL YOU NEED.
THE LEFT CALLS TRUMP HITLER AND
THAT IS THE OPPOSITE OF HITLER.
HE'S A GONDI, AND ORANGE GANDHI.
IT IS WHY THE LEFT IS LOSING IT.
THE LATEST IS PETER FONDA.
[CROWD BOOS]
GREG: HE IS LOST HIS MOTORCYCLE
AND HIS MARBLES.
THIS BRAIN-DEAD BASKETCASE
SUGGESTED KIDNAPPING AND
ASSAULTING DONALD TRUMP'S CHILD.
WHAT DID I SAY BEFORE?
DEEM SOMEONE EVIL AND YOU CAN DO
ANYTHING TO HIM.
THE LIBERAL MANIFESTO IS BOILED
DOWN TO TWO WORDS.
F YOU.
FONDA HAS A MOVIE COMING OUT IN
WHAT ROSEANNE DID WAS COMPARED
TO THIS.
IT'S A DOUBLE STANDARD AND IT
DRIVES.
IT IS NOT JUST FONDA BUT EVERY
CELEBRITY IS ALL CONFORMIST AND
THEY THINK ALIKE, TALK LIKE THAT
AT TIMES THEY WALK ALIKE.
HERE THEY ARE ON THE RED CARPET.
♪
♪.
GREG: NO WONDER THEY HATE TRUMP.
HE'S A BIGGER STAR AND MORE
ENTERTAINING.
WHAT WOULD YOU RATHER WATCH?
SARAH SANDERS REDUCING JIM
ACOSTA TO A PUDDLE?
OR PETER FONDA TRYING TO EAT
PEAS?
IT IS ALL I CAN TAKE.
IT'S NOT ABOUT KIDS BUT ABOUT
2020 AND A WILLINGNESS TO SPLIT
THE COUNTRY OVER.
AMERICA GETS IT.
A LARGE MAJORITY BELIEVE THE
MEDIA IS INHERENTLY BIASED.
OPTIMISM IN THE COUNTRY IS
GROWING AND MORE PEOPLE REJECT
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA JOURNALISTS
GET FURIOUS LIKE MEAN GIRLS
UNINVITED TO THE PROM.
HENCE THE MENTAL CHAOS AND THE
THREAT TO TRUMP'S SON SHOT OUT
TO HITLER.
THE WORLD IS CRUMBLING AND IT
BEGAN WHEN TRUMP WAS ELECTED AND
WHEN PAUL AND HIS ILK PREDICTED
ECONOMIC COLLAPSE.
WRONG AGAIN YOU JACKASSES.
THE ECONOMY IS ON FIRE WHICH IS
THE ONLY REASON YOU CAN AFFORD
THERAPY.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUEST.
HE IS MORE PUNCH LINES THAT HIGH
SCHOOL DANCE, JOE DEVITO.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
SHE IS SO SHARP HER PARENTS
NEVER GAVE HER BALLOONS,
ATTORNEY EMILY CAVALLO.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
MISERY LOVES COMPANY, CAPTAINS.
THERE IS NO DEEP END IN HIS
SUPERSTAR AND MY MASSIVE
SIDEKICK, TYRUS.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
JOE, THIS IS A TEST SUBJECT AND
NO ONE WANTS TO SEPARATE KIDS
BUT WHAT IS WORKING YOU?
>> I THINK THAT SENATOR IS THE
PERFECT OPPORTUNITY.
THAT'S WHEN YOU PRESENT YOUR
MICROPHONE AND EARPIECES DO NOT
WORK.
YOU DON'T JUST START
IF YOU BELIEVE TRUMP IS A BAD
THEN YOU DON'T NEED TO MAKE FAKE
PHOTOGRAPHS AND YOU DON'T NEED
TO REPURPOSE PHOTOGRAPHS FROM
FOUR YEARS AGO.
IT'S A SERIOUS ISSUE AND IT
SHOULD BE TREATED SERIOUSLY
INSTEAD OF IGNORING IT THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE THE REINS OF
POWER FOR THE PAST EIGHT YEARS
IT.
IT WILL NOT BE EASY AND THERE
WILL BE SUFFERING BUT I THINK
WHAT MAKES THE LEFT THE MAD THE
MOST IS PEOPLE WANT TO COME TO
UNITED STATES ON THEIR OWN
VOLITION.
THAT IS WHAT DRIVES THEM NUTS.
THAT MEANS THAT THE UNITED
STATES IS NOT THE WORST RACIST
HELLHOLE FOR NONWHITE PEOPLE
THAT THE FULL VALUE SYSTEM GETS
EXPLODED.
GREG: INTERESTING AND VERY
PERCEPTIVE THOUGHT.
>> I DO WHAT I CAN.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
GREG: EMILY.
YOU ARE THE LEGAL MIND AND I
WANT TO ASK YOU.
TRUMPS SIN IS TRYING TO ENFORCE
LAWS AND HE WILL ENFORCE A LAW
IF THEY CHANGE THE LAW
IF THEY CHANGE THE LAW -- ISN'T
THAT HOW HE IS?
>> HE'S TRYING TO ENFORCE THE
LAW AND RUNNING TO THE SAME
CONUNDRUM THAT OBAMA DID WITH IS
ESSENTIALLY IF YOU PLEASE THE
MASSES THAT ARE NOT IMPOSING THE
LAW AND IF YOU ENFORCE THE LAW
THE PEOPLE ARE UP IN ARMS.
THIS ISSUE IS AN ICEBERG AND THE
REALITY OF OUR SOUTHERN BORDER
AND THE BORDER SECTORS OF IT IS
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THE DRUG
CARTELS BEING THE LINCHPINS BUT
THE MESSAGING THAT HAS BEEN
OVERSUPPLIED BY BOTH SIDES.
WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT WHAT IS
PATINA DRIVING THESE PEOPLE SO
DESPERATELY BORDERS AND WHAT IS
THE FACTORS THAT WE HAVE ON OUR
SIDE WHICH INCLUDES CATCH AND
RELEASE AND UNDER THE FORMER
ADMINISTRATION SO I THINK THE
JOURNALIST DOING THE BEST WORK
THERE PEOPLE LIKE BRANDON DARBY
THEY ARE AMAZING BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT SUBSCRIBING TO THE MESSAGING
AND COMMITTING TO THE FACT THAT
IT IS DIPLOMACY WHICH IS WHERE
WE NEED TO PUT OUR EFFORTS.
THERE IS A LOT MORE PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN THESE CARTELS THAT
ARE FINANCERS AND BANKERS AND
ATTORNEYS THAT THEY ARE FAR MORE
POWERFUL THAN THE CARTEL HEAD
BUT MESSAGING PRODUCES IT.
HOW ARE WE TO COMBAT THE CENTRAL
AMERICAN PROTECTORS AND
PROTECTORS IF WE DON'T KNOW THE
PICTURE?
GREG: EMILY, SMARTEST STUFF THIS
WEEK.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
TYRUS SPEED.
TRYUS: MY MIKE EIGHT FOLLOWING
AND I'M NOT -- ASKED ME ABOUT
DENNIS RODMAN.
GREG: DENNIS RODMAN IS GOING TO
HONDURAS -- NO, WE WERE TALKING
EARLIER AND IT SEEMS LIKE THE
LEFT -- THIS IS CHRISTMAS FOR
THEM.
[LAUGHTER]
TRYUS: YOU FINALLY GOT ONE.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH
IT.
THEY ARE A DOG CHASING A TIRE.
THEY FUMBLE IT AWAY BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE TO PLAY THE HAND.
GREG: THEY OVERPLAYED THEIR
HAND.
TRYUS: IT WAS A BAD WEEK FOR
TRUMP WHEN HE DOES WELL WE HAVE
TO SAY THE JOB WHEN HE IS BAD
WEEK WE HAVE TO SAY HEY, PULL IT
BACK.
THE PATENT DID AND HANDLE IT
RIGHT AND EVERYONE WHEN IT
POSSESSED THEMSELVES THEY SAID
WHAT THEY WANTED TO SAY BECAUSE
IT IS AN UGLY THING.
HERE IN THE STATE ON THE SOCIAL
MEDIA I GOT INTO THIS WEEK IF
SOMEONE IN THE AUDIENCE HAS THE
CHILDREN IN THE CAR WITH THEM
AND THEY GET PUT OVER FOR A
MISDEMEANOR AND THEY GO TO JAIL
THE KIDS GO TO THE SYSTEM.
BEEN ARRESTED AND COMMITTING A
CRIME IS A ROUGH, UGLY THING AND
IT AFFECTS A LOT OF PEOPLE.
YOUR CHILDREN, IF THEY ARE WITH
YOU, IF YOU CHOOSE TO BREAK THE
LAW THEY GO TO THE SYSTEM.
I UNDERSTAND THE REASONS WHY YOU
ARE COMING TO THIS COUNTRY, I
GET IT.
I GREW UP IN CALIFORNIA AND I
WAS AROUND A LOT OF IMMIGRANTS
AND FOR THE MOST PART THEY WERE
THERE TO WORK, RAISE THEIR
FAMILIES AND THEY WORKED HARD.
I THERE IS THAT BAD AN ELEMENT
AND WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO SCREEN
BECAUSE EVEN IF YOU LET IN 500
GREAT HARD-WORKING MUST BE
AMERICAN CITIZENS AND ONE OF
THEM IS A MASS MURDERER, THAT IS
ONE TOO MANY.
WE HAVE TO SCREEN AND THAT AND
DO THOSE THINGS.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
GREG: CAT, DO YOU THINK WHERE
YOU THINK THIS IS GOING WITH THE
CONSTANT NOT THE HITLER
COMPARISON?
WILL THIS END?
KAT: I DID NOT LIKE THE
SEPARATION POLICY.
NOT A FAN GLAD THAT'S NOT A
THING ANYMORE ALTHOUGH I REALLY
JUST GENERALLY DO NOT UNDERSTAND
HOW IT IS NOT TO GERMANY?
I DON'T GET HOW THAT'S EVEN A
COMPARISON.
I'M CONVINCED THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE MAYBE DON'T KNOW WHAT
NAZI GERMANY IS.
GREG: THAT IS A GOOD POINT.
KAT: MAYBE, I THINK IT SPREAD
LIKE WILDFIRE.
FIGURE 1% SAY IT AND THEY SAY
THAT TO FIT IN IS TO AGREE SO
THAT WAY EVERYBODY OR THE THINK
THAT YOU ARE A JERK SO EVERYONE
KEEPS REPEATING IT WITHOUT
REALLY EXPLAINING IT.
>> IF YOU BELIEVE BEING A NAZI
IS BEING IN FAVOR OF SCHOOL
VOUCHERS YOU GIVEN YOURSELF A
WIDE RANGE.
IF ANYONE DOESN'T DISAGREE WITH
YOU THAT'S HOW THEY GET AWAY
WITH IT.
IT'S COMPLETELY ILLOGICAL.
GREG: I THANK YOU ARE A NAZI.
THE IRONIC CONCLUSION HERE AND I
KNOW WE HAVE TO GO BUT TRUMP
GAVE A LOT OF THESE CYNICAL
HYPOCRITES THE WHEREWITHAL TO DO
THE JOB.
THIS IS A PROBLEM THE REPORTERS
ARE NOW GOING AFTER ONLY BECAUSE